speaking of rappers i watched that first
episode of the kanye dog oh god how good
was that yeah i mean uh
so in the most respectful way possible i
i had like a certain idea about kanye
but i didn't you've seen office space
right office space yeah yeah i didn't
realize that kanye was effectively like
the milton of
hip-hop oh that's a good take you know
like okay but you guys said you would
sign me and still even sign me and if
you don't sign me i'm gonna make a
platinum record and they're like okay
that [ __ ] where dame dash was just like
egging him on in the studio and he's
like yeah man he's hot we're gonna sign
him you know you see like kanye's like
this he's like this young boy he was
like [ __ ] yeah and they just don't do it
i know damn i know also anyone can say
what they want about kanye but that dude
lives on another planet because he's
been
that guy since literally like 20. how
crazy was that when he was in his
apartment he's young as [ __ ] he's like
20. he's like yeah you know me it's
kanye i got platinum hits i got a little
song on that album with eminem and [ __ ]
it's like whoa yeah i knew he was like a
great producer i guess i did realize but
it put into perspective how young he was
when he got successful yeah i mean i
think that's why it was especially cool
for people that are our age yeah because
we didn't really see
that part that part of his we weren't
like there first hand
we didn't know about i mean at least i
didn't really know about age to the is
though and even if you knew about that
it's still finding out how big that was
for his career yeah yeah and like i
don't know if you followed hip-hop
during that time you knew about like
chicago hip-hop yeah you knew like what
a name he was but like how much trouble
he had like
transitioning yeah that's a really cool
story and i was like i had no idea about
that well i think like it can yeah it
definitely contextualized a lot of stuff
and i think the crazy part was when you
think about that era of music like jay-z
dominated everything new york had like a
stronghold on music just that whole idea
that like oh if you're from the midwest
like you you're not going to be able to
go like you can't go up you have to
leave
and just like seeing that like even
though he kind of was still breaking
through being from chicago and then
moved and was still having all that
[ __ ] difficulty like damn there was
an article i think in
complex and it was like from rockefeller
and it seemed like they were really
trying to save face it was like this
[ __ ] thing where they were like
trying to really exaggerate kanye
they're like oh no he that whole clip
where he performed the song like we
didn't pay attention to it because he
used to do that all the time and that
but other people were like no he didn't
do that all the time he did that that
one time yeah um like when he went into
the office yeah like that [ __ ] was like
heartbreaking i mean so awkward yeah
oh god yeah
and he's playing a hit and all the all
everyone's sitting there like hey man
can you turn this off yeah get the [ __ ]
out of here yeah i mean that's what's
cool is it like just humanizes him
the way we see him now at least for the
last like five six years is just small
outbursts through the lens of the media
yeah or through his weird instagram
captions that he purposely makes
abstract and weird to promote an album
or something like that that's all we see
and then we get one interview with
charlemagne like every three years or
whatever the [ __ ]
and so to see him
just on the come up like any of us
trying to chase our dreams doing the
same [ __ ] yeah getting taken advantage
of really like but having some hits or
like some successes yeah and just trying
to turn that into something was so
[ __ ] cool yeah it just made him real
in my eyes and i'm like oh okay now i
understand why he is the goat yeah well
so the thing that kind of bugged me out
and and this is where i i've like
fallen off in terms of like tracking i
guess close with like certain people in
hip hop so at the top of the documentary
was his dude rhymefest he was the guy in
the orange shirt and i remember when i
was like in high school in college i
would listen to rhymefest this is when
you know kanye was really blown up and
like underground like backpack nerds
would be like oh man
rhymefest is the one you know writing
all the kanye's [ __ ] you know rhymefest
is the like the reason why kanye's
successful which awful take like not
true at all
but i was under the impression that they
had like a falling out that was weirdly
one of the first things to hit me in the
documentary is i was like oh they're
still friends that's [ __ ] cool yeah
cause i guess for me
knowing like i i i had a skewed lens of
that because then
how people would talk about rhymefest i
would just sort of ingest that and take
it as truth and i'm like oh man well
maybe run fast should be you know
getting more credit and this and that
there's actually a song things off of
rhymefest album can you google search
just rhymefest and kanye west
i forget the name of the song but i
remember watching this [ __ ] i would like
show it to people because people i would
tell people like oh yeah you know kanye
works with this guy from chicago named
rhymefest and i guess like he's written
a lot of stuff for him people wouldn't
believe me and i'd show them this video
and they'd be like what is kanye doing
with this [ __ ] like loser
it was like so hateful
so i don't know i think that was just
really dope and i'm curious to see in
the remaining episodes now go to youtube
um i'm curious to see like if they touch
on their story in any way
because he as far as i know is like a
staple in terms of like how he came up
so i'd be curious to like to see if
there was a falling out and like how
that relationship evolved yeah brand new
oh i love this song did you i [ __ ]
love this yeah dude this is like my
favorite kanye's what what what album
was up so this wasn't off because it's
rhymefest featuring kanye west so what
did i hear this on i heard it on like
mtv or something like that i was
obsessed with it and you could only
listen to it on youtube i'm pretty sure
was it yeah or it was like on sketchy
like music blogs it came out in 05 yeah
this is old as [ __ ]
and then when did um it's such a good
song
let's start the bonus episode with that
song yeah well i i got into kanye
like after he dropped that album that
he's making
in the first episode so i i was like not
privy to any of that stuff yeah
which is it's just cool i don't know
it's just [ __ ] sick to see and it's
also just dope that he's been filming
everything he's been doing for 20 years
and who are you telling you it's crazy
right nobody knew they didn't even
market this at all did they um not
really it was definitely talked about
but yeah it wasn't like heavy heavily
marketed but people knew that it was
coming out and like netflix people were
kind of like sniping clips and like
putting them out like the one of him
going around rockefeller and like
playing the song oh okay yeah i mean
saying and i'm not sitting here like i'm
not like a expert on kanye's career
either i think
i guess all i was trying to say is that
my frame of reference for kanye was okay
after like through the wire i i got to
know more and i'm like oh this dude is
gonna blow up he makes dope music
everyone likes his music and i just
thought he was a really talented dude
from chicago and then when i learned
later about rhyme fest then i had this
like skewed perception of like oh
rhymefest was the one making major
contributions to his career like and i
kind of always had it in my head that
rhymefest was a big catalyst for him to
be successful but already in the first
episode i'm watching he's like oh no
this [ __ ] was like he was it
yeah
i think that's the point is that
everyone has these like preconceived
notions of or or not at all like me yeah
of what it took for him or i guess what
it took for him to have such like a
rabid fan base yeah like every time he
does something weird people are like no
he's still the most creative he's a
genius he's a genius meanwhile i was
like i just think he makes good music
but i didn't really think and then to
get the backstory you're like now i
understand why people say he's a genius
yeah like even like meeting his mom yeah
seeing them interact it's like [ __ ] he
was kind of i don't know what it is
about those clips but it's just he was
destined for this like he was clearly
gonna stop at nothing to make sure that
he people heard his music i mean he was
a star
yeah to the fullest
dude that clip of him
when scarface was in the studio and he's
trying to get him to do the hook on
jesus walks yeah clearly he's like this
is the song and then he plays it and
scarface is like next
yo
my booty hole crusty i was like [ __ ]
yeah
that feeling yeah is the most vulnerable
feeling ever showing someone privately
something creative that you made
that's like a
more nerve-wracking feeling than just
putting it out on youtube because it's
important to you but also like you know
out of all that i have to say i'm
impressed with kanye's um commitment to
dental care seriously yeah the that
[ __ ] had those retainers in
i know but you know what bro it is a
super interesting moment because at that
time like it was just like a lot of
street rappers like really
you know
dominating radio so no one had any
reason to be like yeah this is gonna
yeah you know this is gonna blow yeah um
except that one dude from raucous
records who's like nah man like you hit
a lot of different audiences like you
need to keep going and it's it's crazy
and all that noise and all those people
being like nah [ __ ] you it's like
there's only like these hand-picked
people who could like see the future
like that yeah yeah it is super dope
like seeing the raw vocal takes of like
future hits and doing he's sitting there
playing jesus walks that must be such a
crazy feeling for him and everyone who
watched like especially the videographer
cootie like watching that being like oh
like these [ __ ] were so wrong
yeah so wrong yeah bro and then how he
pulled out the the pen and pad and acted
like he was gonna write something and
then just was like i can't
i know i know i felt that you feel that
because it's like that's such a huge
opportunity for kanye's sitting there
like just hoping and praying something
would happen i think at that time like
when you contextualize what it was like
to hear that music
if everything around you is sort of like
um
like a tougher
tone right like
in terms of the writing the presentation
of the music and then he's playing these
beats where it's featuring samples like
gee this walks people probably heard
that they're like oh this is like weird
this is like christian yeah it's too
soft yeah you know they're taking it
literally yeah you know yeah and they're
not seeing like oh no this is like a
crazy down the middle yeah where like
this could hit a [ __ ] ton of people they
can't see it that way yeah because why
would they yeah
it's a very reminiscent of you know
little pumps
yeah definitely yeah definitely to
remind me of yeah yeah yeah kanye and
lil pump definitely have the same career
yeah
you